so we've got a few more topics the the
next topic is fitting neural networks
and you see we put the the little uphill
car there because this this is
potentially a little bit more
challenging challenging
sorry can i leave now can you leave that
now this is if you can if you're going
to fall asleep please don't snow it's
fascinating stuff okay
so we put up a picture of our simplest
neural network
we put an objective say sum of squares
and we want to minimize the sum of
squares
and we've expanded
f of x8
and you see
we've got parameters beta and the w's in
this simple little one we've got
training data we've got n observations
we want to minimize sum of squares that
means we want to learn the w's and the
beta
from those data okay
turns out the problem is difficult
because the objective is non-convex
and we'll show you what that means in a
moment
it turns out
however despite this the effective
that effective algorithms have evolved
that can optimize complex neural
networks um efficiently so let's look at
that in a little bit more detail
so here's a non-convex function we just
show you a one-dimensional function
and we're going to use gradient descent
to optimize this function
so you can see here
we write the the function now we we use
the collective term theta to represent
all the parameters
so our objective we write as r of theta
and it's the sum of squares
and theta consists of all the w's and
the beta right and now we try and depict
it in one dimension
and the way gradient descent works is
you start with some guess for theta and
we start off with a guess over here
and this orange curve here
is the function r of theta
so if theta was one-dimensional
this is a non-convex function
which what that means is
it doesn't have a single minimum it's
got this one's got two minimas right it
comes down and then goes up again it's
got lots of hills and valleys two in two
valleys in this case
and
what gradient descent does is you start
at a guess
you figure out a direction to move in
this case we're either going to go left
or right and you move a little bit in
that direction
and you pick the direction so that
you're going downhill because we want to
get to a minimum
and so you go downhill a little away and
you get to the next guess
and you keep on doing that moving down
here or moving downhill until you can't
move downhill anymore
okay
and so in this case
we get down
to this point which is
as far as we know a local minimum
actually in this picture it looks like a
global minimum
if we started a little bit to the left
of the starting point we would have gone
in the opposite direction and got and
got caught up in a local minimum
so that's our gradient descent works
okay
so the trick is to find
these directions to move so this in one
dimensional as i said you only go left
or right a certain distance but when
you're in higher dimensions you have to
decide which direction to move
in in that parameter space and how much
to move in that direction
so a little bit more detail
in in the simplex as i said we reach the
global minimum if we start a little to
the left of theta naught we would have
got to a local minimum
and if the dimensions higher we have to
decide in the direction
so how to find the direction delta that
points downhill well we need to compute
what's known as the gradient vector
and the gradient vector
computed at some current point theta
t
is the vector of derivatives of the
function
which is a function of this
multiparameter theta
at each of the coordinates of theta
so if if theta's got
m coordinates
this gradient vector is going to be an m
vector
and consists of what's known as partial
derivatives okay
now
it's a fact of calculus that the
gradient always points uphill
so the gradient has components in it and
tells you which direction in space to
move
if you move a little bit in that
direction you're going to be going
uphill
so that means the way we want to move is
the opposite of the gradient so we put a
minus sign in front of the gradient and
that will make us go downhill which is
what we want to do
and then we multiply it by some small
number rho you can see row here is .001
that's a typical number
and that says
you know this gradient is going to
recommend a certain distance to go as
well as direction
we want to be really cautious so we we
want to just go small a little bit in
that direction
to make sure we we're going downhill
because you can overstep and end up the
gradient maybe off and if you go the
full distance you can start going up
again
so this row is a way of slowing things
down
and so that leads to the update in the
parameter
theta t plus one is theta t minus rho
times the gradient
if this is a little beyond your math
skills don't worry this is
built into the the algorithms that we
use and you know this is just to give
you for those who understand the culture
it's a way of understanding what's going
on so let me go back to the previous
picture there
one of the things that makes this area
so complex and it's actually a very hot
area now in in machine learning
optimization figuring out algorithms for
neural networks
even if you could you could get the
global minimum on the right there it's
not clear that we that's the solution
you want right remember the example we
had with 60 000 observations and
200 thousand parameters yeah the global
minimum could be overfit quite badly yes
so
we don't even even if we could get the
global minimum we often don't want it
so there's a lot of study now about of
the of the grading the sentence to cast
a grade in a sentence figures out just
tries to figure out just what solution
does it find yes because it seems to
work well in practice but people don't
really understand that yeah exactly
i think in in the early days of neural
networks they they would
you know you have to start at some value
they'll pick some small value to random
value to start with they'd fit the
network many times starting at different
random values and average the solutions
and that turned out to be a better thing
to do than just go to one global minimum
so i'm saying typically these problems
can have thousands of local minima right
and
just which one we want and which one the
algorithms tend to find is really not
clear yeah
okay
so there's a gradient
now you thought if you thought if you
thought this was complex
this slide's even more complex
okay
okay so how do we compute the gradients
so there's there's a technique called
back propagation so again let's look at
the simplest case
we see the loss function
r of theta is actually a sum from 1 to n
of r i of theta
right because it's just summed over the
observations
and r i of theta i've just written it
out here is
y i minus f theta of x i squared
and in expanded form we can write it
like this
well
when we compute the gradient of r of
theta
the way gradients works is you can
compute the gradient of each of these
components and then sum them then you
get the gradient of r of theta because r
of theta is a sum over these n terms we
can compute the gradient of each piece
and then sum to get the gradient so now
we need to be able to compute the the
derivative
of this function with respect to all the
betas and all the w's
okay
so just a bit of notation we'll let z k
be
the the linear combination inside here
just for ease of no calculation
so now we use what's known as the chain
rule of differentiation
so
let's first differentiate with respect
to a beta
so if we we first differentiate the sum
of squares with respect to f of theta
and then f of theta with respect to beta
okay
and when you do it in those two steps
and then multiply them together this is
what you get this expression over here
for the ws
we do differentiate with respect to f of
theta again
then f of theta with respect to g of of
z k
g of z k with respect to
z k and then z k with respect to w so
four steps in the chain
and when you do each of those and
multiply them together you get this
expression over here
and
the nice thing here in this example in
squared error loss we see that the first
piece in both of them is the residual
so the residual is telling you what
error you're making for that observation
and
what you can think of
these multipliers on the residual they a
way of spreading the residual down to
all the different units that are
responsible for that residual
right so you propagate in the residual
backwards to the
the activations and and and therefore
the weights in the in the network
and so this is a simple network but the
same idea gets used on the most complex
networks and the nice thing today is
you can have
the computer programs know how to
automatically differentiate functions
and so we don't even have to think about
it just gets done automatically okay so
this i agree this is quite technical but
this is a technical section and and
that's the idea of
[Laughter]
i backpropagation not go over it again
i guess importantly there's some tricks
of the trade
so one is slow learning
so it turns out gradient descent is a
slow way of optimizing
and a small learning rate row even slows
it further
and so one of the ideas is to use early
stopping as a form of regularization
so even though you've got a very highly
parametrized network and if you fit it
all the way down until you reach a
minimum you're going to overfit
the gradient descent is a nice slow way
of getting there and if you stop early
you may end up in a really good spot
we saw that with a
with the
imdb
reviews when we train the network there
was a figure
the the performance of the the network
on the test data it peaked very quickly
at around 0.88 and then started going
down
that was those epochs were measuring
iterations of training
what's used pretty much in all neural
networks now is stochastic gradient
descent
and
what what you do is rather than compute
the gradient using all the data you use
a small mini batch drawn at random at
each step
so for example with mnist you've got 60
000 training observations
but you may use a mini batches of just
128 observations drawn at random from
those training data
so you take 128 observations you compute
the gradient based on them and you make
your small gradient to step just using
them
you can imagine that cuts down on the
computation dramatically
okay
so we talked of epochs
so the epoch is a count of iterations
and it amounts to the number of mini
batch updates such that end samples in
total have been processed
right so if we use 128 it's going to be
60 000 over 128 which means
469
mini batch updates amounts to going
through
an equivalent of n or the full n
training sample 60 000
that's an epoch in addition we use
regularization so ridge and lasso
regularization can be used to shrink the
weights at each layer
and two other popular forms of
regularization are drop out and
augmentation
which we're going to discuss next
so what you do with dropout
is a simple little network and you can
see the original network and here we've
colored some of the units gray we've
colored the input unit gray and we've
color colored two of the hidden units
gray
so at each
mini batch stochastic gradient descent
update what you do is randomly remove
units with probability phi
maybe 0.4 or something like that
and scale up the weights of those
retained by
an amount to compensate it turns out you
want to do 1 over 1 minus phi
just remove those units and ignore them
so in simple scenarios like linear
regression
it turns out a version of this process
can be shown to be equivalent to ridge
regularization
so as in ridge the other units stand in
for those temporarily removed and their
weights are drawn closer together
and so that's become a very popular form
for for regularization of deep networks
and of course it speeds up the learning
as well because you've got less units to
process
it's similar to randomly emitting
variables when growing trees in random
forests so if you remember in random
forests when each time you get a
bootstrap sample you train a tree you
randomly ignore
subsets or variables it's the same idea
and the inventors of dropout acknowledge
random forests and leo brymen's
contribution there
the other
interesting
form of regularization is called
data augmentation
okay
so here's a picture this two-dimensional
picture
the orange points are your actual data
points you can see the data they've just
got x1 and x2 they somewhat correlated
what we do is in this case we've
randomly added a little cloud of data
points around each original data point
so we augment the data set with random
versions of the original data point with
a little bit of noise
okay
but for each of those
we use the same y value as the original
data point
so we've just perturbed the feature
point by these random doors okay
so what this does
is makes the fit robust to small
perturbations in each of the xi's
and it turns out in in an ordinary least
square setting this is exactly
equivalent to ridge regularization
okay
so that's just the heuristic that we
want to use
in the case for images
so in images what you can do
is something similar
each time you draw a mini batch for
stochastic gradient descent
you draw an image let's say it's one of
the 128 images you're going to draw at
random you draw an image and then at
random you apply some natural
transformation to that image
like you rotate the tiger's head a
little bit
you enlarge it a little bit
you change the attitude you stretch it
you maybe change the color or the you
but these transformations
are all transformations that wouldn't
confuse a human we'll still recognize
this as a tiger
so you can think of this as as creating
around the original tiger a cloud
of
different versions of the same tiger but
somehow they all represent that same
tiger so that's like adding the random
noise and of course the label for all of
those images is tiger
okay
and
when you do that
it improves the performance a lot
and
you can think of it as a form of of
ridge regularization
in the community they think of it as
augmentation you're just increasing the
training sample size which of course is
going to
you know that's that's going to prevent
overfitting because now you've got a
bigger a training sample size you can
fit the model more accurate accurately
but through this heuristic you can think
of it as a form of ridge regularization
it sounds like we do more than just
regularized but also make it more robust
for future predictions right yes because
if the system was presented with a
rotated tiger
you might not normally recognize it yeah
and and this idea has been around for a
while wasn't it
yeah
yeah
so these
you can think of these as hints you put
it in different versions of the tiger
and you say by the way these are also a
tiger and you don't you know you don't
have to get new data you can just do
that